here's something I learned about when I
was writing the book the white pill
about the Soviet Union you can you know
sit there and you could be like there's
nothing you could do to me I'm gonna be
the nominee I'm gonna run I'm gonna run
there's nothing I don't care you throw
the charges you want what these
totalitarian regimes do and I'm not
saying we're in a total regime but I'm
just saying what evil people do they go
that's cool you've got a wife right and
you've got kids right and you've got
grandkids right okay cool we're not
gonna do anything to you so very quickly
when you start targeting those people
everyone starts to fold and with good
reason so they have a lot of those cards
to play and I wouldn't put it past them
there was especially with the the Trump
organization indictments I'll keep this
vague that's true because of that but
there was an individual who was running
who dropped out uh recently and this had
been discussed publicly but I'm not
going to say the individual's name
because they're family but they dropped
out because of the risk of their family
yeah and this was like a trump Maga
candidate and so we'll just leave it at
that but this is a reality yes